ja und ich dir einfach ich auch du bist
auch da wäre ich auch selbst in wald und
wiese nicht das einzige lied was ich von
denen kenne
hallo ich in meinem leben fordern
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft für leute die bis der waffel
hdm hinter gittern gegen dabei in der
staffel wirkte sich auf youtube um in
eine waffel hd wenn zehn leute dafür
stehen also gibt ein wenig wie die
zuhause abstimmung wenn ihr wollt dass
ja das thema für sich
ich war hatte eigentlich gedacht mit mia
farrow zu machen allerdings haben wir ja
schon
und ja ich weiß gar nicht was könnte ich
den baum
ich bin zurzeit ein bisschen am
vorproduzieren weil ich vom samstag
sonntag oder dienstag vier tage weg bin
aber das soll euch nicht kümmern folgen
werden natürlich kommen
staffel mache ich jetzt hier einem
beispielsweise mal dann die leute die
mich richtig hassen hinterließen vor
irgendwie mai kräften aber das ist ja
egal jetzt für eine farce ich glaube das
könnte ich könnte mein haushalter baum
was sollte ich denn da machen noch mal
und zwar wollte ich hier was kann ich
machen ich wollte erst mal ach ich
wollte ja diese geilen bäume holen
weiße baums die boxee box genau die
euros habe ich eigentlich oder habe ich
da noch setzlinge für birke eiche habe
ich nicht aber ich hab noch ganz viele
samen finde ich
oder hat die verbote für mich vielleicht
nicht geerntet wir brauchen einfach noch
mal ein feld sind zweite sie aber auch
so wieder brauchen fällt einfach ja es
stimmt ich glaub ich noch mein feld dann
kriege ich sogar die dass ich tief meint
dass ich ein feld ab jetzt echt ich
meine wenn ich mir angucke
die aktie fällt die welt hielt inserent
in gleiwitz ja jedenfalls erkenntnis
freunde minecraft fries wir haben
natürlich wieder ein paar sein
am start die uns bald wieder geschrieben
wurde
okay es geht mit dem wunderbare twitter
fragen und zwar fragt wo sind schon
lecker was tun wenn's kreis ewiglich
oder sieben ja die heißt glaube ich man
rät manuela kurios sind schon lecker
goals & decker ist der twitter name war
okay was fragt sie einfach die frage
gestellt was hast du den adventskalender
ok und was hat sie gefragt
ich habe keinen hass
ich hab ein monatlich bekommen wir ein
lego adventskalender von wem hast du ihn
bekommen meine cousine von meiner großen
einen lego adventskalender kekulé lego
adventskalender find ich echt auch cool
marco dir kurzem aber ich hatte die
letzten jahre immer so ein mit fußball
und so aber dann dass letztlich ein mit
lillifee und da war ich so enttäuscht
von dem tag ein kleines kritik für die
lücken der hübsch hässlich oder lillifee
adventskalender schade drum
ja ja die auch gerne in seinem kleinen
tutu gesehen ich hätte ich auch gerne
zum kleinen tür gesehen ich habe gar
nicht schauen
okay gut ich sehe dich auch mal hier und
ja ich weiß jetzt nehmen wir okay so
dann würde ich sagen wir weiter und dann
kommt die weihnachtliche frage die
weihnacht weihnachts willkommen in der
legasthenie genau hallo
das staffel immer wenn er irgendwie was
aufnimmt oder so ja ich bin
schrecklicher mensch aber das ist man
die leute fragt wusstest du dass jan von
ape crime ein direction reis der agenda
weihnachts frage uli das ist richtige
weihnachtstag auf jeden fall wollte dir
einfach ich auch du bist auch da wäre
ich auch zum inhalt und da er weder das
einzige was ich von ihnen kenne noch
dieses andere werte es gibt noch das
andere stimmen das sind auch immer da
wurde das mit dem mitleid ich bin voll
machen können wenn uns ja genau das hat
schon die kommentare
okay fragt final jam fragt was war das
beste geschenk das sie jemals bekommen
ist
wir werden nochmal zäune gemacht haben
sie geändert jetzt tatsächlich in etwas
watte und keine freundin gefunden
links rechts links rechts place und in
der mitte sticks teilstück über 92 was
wie wo was wie katy perry ist links
links zwei planes zweite jajaja
übereinander
ja ok übereinander
doch jetzt gehts aber ich hatte ich
hatte die vermischt ich hatte birkenholz
und eichenholz mit drin
nun ja gerade zählen nicht nur wegen den
farben hoch fliegenden fahrt brauche ich
ja extra eichenholz um dieser eichenholz
teile hier zufrieden was ein schwachsinn
schlafen fragezeichen jedes mädchen
zusammen bitte bei mir jemand was
hingebaut er schöne schöne
blumen fluten nicht bluten acht minuten
okay weil wir antworten so die reden die
frage dass sie an eine erektion ist also
liebe ich finde ich toll unten zahlen
sogar wird würde das beste geschenk das
beste geschenk beantwortet eigentlich
nehmen das beste geschenk das ich je
bekommen habe das habe ich einen anderen
folge schon mal gesagt aber du guckst
natürlich nicht meine videos immer deine
videos ein anderes würde ich
du bist doch der willicher freund
gefragt max wirklich keine waffeln
also nein das sind doch meine
geschwister hat er gesagt ich jetzt auch
keine feature freunde freunde hatte ich
meine erste super gerne oder was skandal
mit respekt konkret ein abonnenten
nehmen
da geht richtig gesagt diese niekrawitz
8 watt doch ich mache jetzt richtig
viele treppen links eichenholz für die
heim noch ab und sagen ich mach jetzt
auch eine kleine farm aber ich weiß
nicht siehst sondern hinten raus aber
ich weiß nicht wie groß die werden soll
kostenblöcke butter ist müller wohl aber
der familie frank
ich heiße ich wie oder kann ich die
schönen design
ja ich habe nie de ich habe eine idee
wohin und wann ich werde glaube ich
denke ich auf sich ich gehe werde glaube
ich denke ich ich hätte demnächst auch
of screen ein bisschen öfters hier
spielen weil ich bin zwar unterwegs aber
ich hab' laptop mit und dann weiß ich
nicht was ich machen soll dann wenig
verständlich einfach minecraft spielen
und jugend server und ich habe auch echt
bock dass ich jetzt hier langsam was
geschissen kriege und zwar habe ich eine
coole idee ich jetzt noch nicht sagen
das hört aber sie ist cool
ja das kann sein ja ich kaufe mir das
jetzt mal ab aber diese listen die wir
noch mal machen weil ich bin mit ideen
immer direkt hören dankeschön
ok ich kann ihn da schon mal flüstern
warte kommen wir gleich behandelt wir
treffen uns in zehn sekunden bei mir
form von der farm ins 19
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
bei der comcom her gehöre ich wünsche
dir doch in den mund
du kannst auch du kannst kein
tschechisch erfüllte sie psychisch das
ist nicht wahr wenn man fest
tschechische team sprechen aber du weißt
was machen möchte ja ich weiß du machen
willst das nicht gesehen hätte dich cool
das wird richtig ins kommission einen
kommentar abgibt die steuer wirklich
wollte nicht wirklich miteinander reden
die natürliche geheimsprache oder spaß
beim echten nennt sich halt dieses
richtig
man muss erst mal wenn man die sprache
lernen möchte muss man erst mal einen
kurs besuchen wie man die sprache
ausspricht
deswegen auch sagt man die beste sprache
die es gibt und wie wild auf jeden fall
aber auch die am schwierigsten zu lernen
weil die an schon gemerkt beim bei uns
die sätze waren alle total
unterschiedlich und jetzt wahrscheinlich
gar nicht verstehen was wir sagen
wollten dagegen habe alles verstanden
werden denn er natürlich wir haben alles
verstanden
sie sind ja auch drücken wir sind aus
die könnte nämlich auch nicht verstehen
noch nicht zumindest du gesagt hast das
war tatsächlich mein erster fernseher
hatte das weiß ich noch da war ich so
happy
deswegen habe ich bis heute noch
studiert auch noch in einer wohnung
steht er ja genau der ich dachte
ab alien als eltern die importieren
das fach richtig da war ich
vor fast zehn jahren ungefähr glaube ich
also dass so ein ganz kleiner so ganz
ganz klein so ein so mineuren filmen ja
den ländern wie auch damals und habe ich
mich immer bei meiner mutter aus
bügelbrett kirkel setzt man hat da die
man geguckt als ich zur schule gekommen
und so dann seien echt geile hatte
wirklich nur an gemacht hat die geguckt
und was dann das lied damals sogar noch
rtl2 und so wo erhält seiner nicht so
diese anrufe auch hatte und alles ist
man schon sehr sehr geil wo rtl noch
okay dann haben wir mehr fragen
natürlich jenny tumor ggp frau infrage
er hat es schon mal einen unfall wie ein
weihnachtsbaum mit einem weihnachtsbaum
ich bin ein tollpatschiger mensch und
die picken mich jedes jahr auch wenn ich
handschuhe an habe irgendwie ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt im märz kinderlied
das ist ja
robin schulz bestätigt alles was diesem
lied sei diese kennt wahrscheinlich ist
es liegt was einfach im radio läuft
heute sind es bei ich hab vor den augen
von robin schulz wenn es anders down ist
das treibt mich das lied für einmal
beide scheiße die er da wieder fabrik
entschuldigung ich bin eine maradona
dessen sein
hattest du ja schon in welche unfälle
mit unfälle auch diverse male
christbaumkugeln runter geschleudert bei
bild.de ich wollte mal ein fahrzeug
machen aber ich hab's ganz nicht ich
weiß nicht ich will hier unten halt ich
sag jetzt mal trotzdem die idee weil
jetzt vielleicht auch psychisch ich
nicht verstanden
ich möchte hier unten seinen kleinen das
haben können sie sich wahrscheinlich
schon ihre denken damals eine treppe von
hier
ich mache am tunnel hier so hin und dann
kann man von hier so hier runter gehen
oder kommen von hier
ich mache das jetzt mal so provisorisch
erstmal hier durch diesen gang moment
den man jetzt noch eben bevor ihr die
folge ende der staffel möchte mich auch
live stream und ihr geht schon hier soll
das dann so in etwa durch gehen und dann
ist man hier nachher bei mir
in dem hallo hier ist man hier kommt man
raus und das wird dann so denke ich so
irgendwie der weg sein wo man so
durchgehen kann also nicht so schräg
aber der wird dann so ein bisschen eckig
sein und mit sowas allem da kann man
hier einerseits in die höhle um zu
fahren und andererseits auch unten in
meinen keller und dann würde ich auch
sagen damit war es das für diese folge
minecraft fries wenn es euch gefallen
hat ich hatte einfach gar keinen ton ich
weiß nicht ob letzten ton gespielt
ich habe mich wirklich gestört die
musikmesse lauter gedreht
dazu gar nichts mehr
die nächste folge habe ich wieder ton am
start und dann vielleicht mit einem
anderen gast vielleicht auch alleine
ich gehe auf jeden fall wieder auf ein
paar fragen einen dank an stoffen dass
er dabei war dass ich mein minecraft
free stream könnt ihr mir bei eurem oder
allgemein x stream vielleicht sagt er
auch nie das passt nicht zu dir oder
stich oder so riesig ich dann schreibt
wir vielleicht in kommentare sonst meint
rich profi steht auch in der
beschreibung weil ich nur überfüllt